bonjour louis camaïeu merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors on
l'a vu un
les combats continuent dans la région du
tigré malgré un cessez le feu qu'elle
est là la situation sur place et
pourquoi les combats continuent les
combats continuent parce que le
porte-parole de la diplomatie
éthiopienne d'addis un retrait
unilatéral une une cessez le feu déclaré
de façon unilatérale par les autorités
éthiopiennes et au niveau des autorités
de deux tigres et cela a été utilisé
comme un moyenne de accentuer davantage
sur le terrain militaire
et c'est pour ça que les combats
continuent les ans dit qu'il
continuerait le combat
peut-être même jusqu à addis abeba
c'était nécessaire et donc cela signifie
que d'un côté il ya une volonté eu de
cessez le feu qui avait été demandé par
l'onu et par les organisations
humanitaires
mais que du côté des tigres et des
autorités qui sont en train de combattre
ce taux est essentiel et choqué il a
passé de même planté là et donc des
combats continuent de leur côté
donc effectivement vous parlez de d'une
décision unilatérale est ce que on
pourrait peut-être imaginer sous la
pression de l'onu des organisations
internationales peut être une situation
qui pourrait s'apaiser dans les semaines
dans les mois à venir
c'est à souhaiter je pense qu'il est
elle souhaitait que l'ethiopie retrouve
son unité et que au delà de l'unité la
stabilité aussi revient dans les
différentes régions notamment dans le
cycle et parce que n'oublions pas le
schéma de 1981 qui avait conduit à
l'indépendance de l'erythrée qui est
vendu comme la solution ultime ou
permettra aux élus cré de retrouver la
liberté et tout ce qu'ils aient tout ce
à quoi désespérer il aspirait en tant
que citoyen c'est à peu près le même
schéma qui se poursuit et je pense
qu'entre les deux aient eu
l'indépendance du soudan du sud
également ne faut pas oublier que si les
tubes et si chère à la fée et à sa
diaspora
c'est parce que d'une part l'union
africaine a son siège
ces bébés d'autre part les diasporas
africaines à commencer par les états où
le mouvement rastafari qui a porté le
reggae ont toutes deux références en et
yuki et que ceux qui arrivent à
l'ethiopie c'est à l'afrique que cette
bougie directement
donc il est important pour les tubes qui
aujourd'hui de retrouver son unité et sa
fierté
ce qui est dommage c'est qu'on entende
pas beaucoup la voient l'union africaine
mais toutes les voies qui seront
nécessaires pour ramener le calme en
ethiopie et surtout dans cette région du
tigré seront bienvenus parce que les
autorités le comprennent les tigres est
un qui sont en combat et ont
pratiquement à ces sessions avec addis
abeba le comprendront également
il n'y a pas je ne pense pas qu'il y ait
une issue favorable à une vérité
aujourd'hui d'indépendance la par du
silicone comme nous l'entendons elle
week-end m'avez vous parlais à l'instant
de l'union africaine qu'elle pourrait
être justement le rôle que pourrait dire
justement l'union africaine pour
justement calmer un petit peu la
situation dans la région du tigré la
situation dans le cibler et celle que
l'on à l'ona train de vivre aujourd'hui
dans la plupart des pays africains c'est
à dire quand il a non seulement une
grave crise économique est là depuis les
années 80 et des tubes money également
une très grande famille
appelez-vous canton chanter we are the
world c'était pas apporté du riz
opposant trois éthiopiens
l'union africaine doit aujourd'hui
prendre ses responsabilités parce que la
crise la situation de crise sanitaire va
aggraver les crises politiques et
sociales qui ont président ait existé
avant cette crise sanitaire et à côté de
ça il ya toutes les difficultés
politiques auxquels les pays font face
et c'est parce qu'il ya eu un malentendu
sur le plan politique entre les
autorités fédérales et l'état fédéré du
tigre et que l'on a débouché sur ce
conflit là qui a été exacerbée juste
avant les élections d'il ya quelques
mois de juin dernier dont je crois qu'il
est important pour l'union africaine
pèse de tout son poids pour que le
dialogue politique et social
même s'il semble aujourd'hui
impossible se rétablisse t que les
frères éthiopien qu'il soit d'asmara ou
d'ailleurs arrive à se reparler pour
tisser le tissu national qui est très
sérieusement déchirés ou à côté de cette
crise politique
louis keumayou on a aussi une crise
humanitaire à l'onu affirment que 350
mille personnes souffrir de la famine
dans la région
est ce que la communauté internationale
doit aussi jouer un rôle dans cette dans
cette crise justement à sanitaires oui
la communauté nationale paul d'ailleurs
je pense que l'angle berne des états
unis et l'islande ont demandé que le
conseil de sécurité se prononce sur les
crises en ethiopie dans le tigré mais il
faut que ce ne soit pas seulement des
déclarations qui concerne le lobby
militaire
il faut de vrais moyens aujourd'hui pour
remettre l'ethiopie et la région du
tigré d'andorre en ordre de marche pour
que les raisons de la colère qui ont
précédé cette crise mais qui l'ont
amplifié que c'est désolant soit écartée
à des voies politiques économiques et
sociales
et malheureusement les solutions qui
sont apportées aux équipements
militaires le conseil de sécurité va te
présenter il y aura probablement un an
barbeau qui sera prononcée contre lui
l'ethiopie pour qu'elle n'ait plus
d'armes entre les replays pour qu'elle
ne s'agira plus dans le dossier
mais ce n'est pas de cela que mais les
populations ciblées elles se plaisent
elles se plaignent parce qu'elles sont
mal prises en compte
mal prises en charge par les autorités
fédérales et les autorités fédérales
n'ont pas assez de moyens on distribue à
tout le monde parce que c'est elle qui
crée aujourd'hui demande
c'est ce que demande la plupart des
éthiopiens justement la plupart des
africains et je crois que cela signifie
qu'ils font une réponse massive
aujourd'hui sur le plan économique et
financier entre les tubes comme tous les
arts il à prendre en charge leurs
populations en détresse
merci
cool louis keumayou d'avoir été avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france je rappelle
que vous êtes c'est le président du club
de l'information africaine merci
beaucoup